[Musique]
c'est là où il faut être deux
il y en a un qui garde le loup la bête
aux jumelles et avec le Tokyo qui se
passe facile parce que il faut dire
voilà à gauche à droite puis l'autre il
part en direction de la bête avec la
lampe torche qui est assez puissante la
nuit là tu éclaire très très loin et
puis un sifflet et tu siffles jusqu'à ce
qu'ils partent le loup la peur il y en a
deux il y a deux loups
en face de moi
[Musique]
il attend maman il pense que tout est
calme le nouveau pour descendre nous
dire bonjour et voir si que ça travaille
du tout pour
[Musique]
pas vouloir faire changer le point de
vue des agriculteurs mais on veut
essayer de créer une intelligence
collective faire travailler les gens
ensemble et permettre de d'avoir
vraiment un dialogue
[Musique]
rêve que du matin et du café voilà c'est
le meilleur moment de la journée ça
c'est le café on va rentrer se coucher
[Musique]